so today let's talk about the master
antioxidant
glutathione now what is an antioxidant
well to understand that you have to
understand what a free radical is
you take an atom with paired electrons
okay if one of those electrons is
missing we have an it's called an
unpaired electron
making it unstable so that's called a
free radical
it's not very balanced and it can create
a lot of destruction
throughout the cells the cell machinery
the dna etc
so an antioxidant comes along and
donates
an electron to balance it out and
stabilize it
the problem is that antioxidant now
loses its electron and it becomes
unstable
it has to get electron from another
antioxidant so
this is why you have antioxidants in
networks
and this is why you should never take a
synthetic antioxidant
because they've been known to cause
cancer why because
synthetic antioxidants don't come in
networks
they come as an individual synthetic
antioxidant
so once they donate their electron they
become
the problem they become the free radical
and that can create all sorts of damage
glutathione has been majorly studied
there's over a hundred thousand peer
review papers
in scientific journals on this one
compound glutathione it's the most
abundant antioxidant in the liver but
all your cells make it and so it reduces
oxidative stress
so if we're going to start balancing out
these free radicals we're going to
reduce the amount of
oxidation and stress of the body your
body also makes free radicals for
various things
killing microbes breaking down certain
things in chemical reactions
it even makes hydrogen peroxide
glutathione is there to help neutralize
some of these toxins that your body
actually makes for various things
also glutathione helps maintain
something called exogenous antioxidants
exogenous are those things that are
outside the body
so glutathione will help maintain
antioxidants that come from the diet
like vitamin c and vitamin e glutathione
this antioxidant that our body makes
helps
maintain these other antioxidants that
we get from the diet
and also these other antioxidants that
we take get from the diet
can also help maintain glutathione
glutathione not only acts as an
antioxidant
it also helps in detoxification
there are three phases of detoxification
phase one phase two phase
three where your body will take a poison
and through different enzyme reactions
breaks down that poison into a harmless
particle
and then gets rid of it through either
the skin
uh the kidney through the urine or the
bowel
which actually comes through the liver
and the bile and then through the
intestine
so your body is constantly trying to get
rid of stuff that's not good for it
it's the most abundant sulfur
antioxidant okay
all your cells make it but it's probably
primarily
most concentrated in the liver because
it's sulfur
if you consume certain foods that are
higher and softer
you will actually give your body the raw
material to make more glutathione
so take a wild guess what the
sulfur-based vegetables are
you guessed it cruciferous so eating
cruciferous vegetables will help you
with this right here also getting enough
vitamin c
from vegetables or other types of
vegetables will also
help you make more glutathione selenium
is a good trace mineral to help
build up glutathione as well milk
thistle strengthens the
liver cell so then your body can make
more glutathione
and also fasting will increase the
network
of antioxidants in the body which is
actually quite fascinating you would
think that by not eating it would shrink
the pool
of antioxidants it does just the reverse
it increases
so with age we decrease our ability to
make this
we drink too much alcohol stress
take drugs toxins over time
it decreases the glutathione a lot of
times people neglect the antioxidant
networks they're very very important
at neutralizing toxic things they're
also involved in
detoxification and these are a few
things you can do to make sure you don't
run out of glutathione
as well as your other antioxidant
networks that you need